it is great to be joined today by sam
quinones who is author of the new york
times bestseller dreamland the true tale
of america's opiate epidemic and most
recently the least of us true tales of
america and hope in the time of fentanyl
and meth uh sam it's great to have you
on i appreciate it
thank you for having me david good to
good to be with you so i mean just from
just from the titles of the two books
right there's been a change in in uh
what is happening in the united states
as as far as drugs go can you talk a
little bit about i mean how has the
landscape changed from when you were
researching the first book and then now
the second the the most recent one
sure of course it it it really has
changed dramatically uh
i and quite unexpectedly to me honestly
um uh when i was writing the first book
the idea was to write the story of how
we had gone from a country that uh had
uh decided or a medical establishment
that decided decided the idea was a good
one to um
massively and excessively in my opinion
um uh prescribed narcotic painkillers
opioid painkillers for all manner of
pain that they had not been used
for before and and not just that but but
like lots of refills and and kind of
under uh with the understanding or the
belief that that these pills would not
be at all addictive to anyone who was a
who was a pain patient
that um helped a lot of people fair to
say it also created an enormous new
population of people who actually were
addicted to these pills who depended on
these bills they they
went to the street uh couldn't find them
very well on the street uh it was very
expensive and eventually they a certain
percentage of those folks um moved on to
uh to to heroin these pills are are have
the drugs in them are very similar to
heroin the underworld um then took over
and that's what led to the next book the
underworld began particularly in the
mexican trafficking world began
providing the heroin um they then
figured out that actually it's a much
better idea to make a synthetic form of
heroin which we now know is fentanyl uh
you don't need any any uh um any any of
the issues that you know land or any of
that kind of stuff and and so the
transformation kind of began
uh
really about five years ago not long
after dreamland came out you began to
see fentanyl kind of take over and and
now the country is
essentially effectively covered with
fentanyl which is an opioid but of but a
synthetic one you don't make use use
plants to make it and that means that
you can make it uh year round if you
have the chemicals at the same time
methamphetamine has also now uh covered
the country because of a new way of
making that as well and so you see
really we're in the era of synthetic
drugs whereas before it was it was the
doctors and uh the classic underworld
providing heroin now it's pretty much
the entire uh source comes from the
underworld and it's now just synthetic
yes in our supply in advance of our
interview i read an article that
the exact name i now don't remember but
it's something like uh can you even
really call it meth anymore and it talks
about how now this this mechanism called
p2p is being used for the manufacture of
math can you talk about why that's been
so crucial to the dominance of meth
sure that was an excerpt of the book in
fact that that was that was run in the
atlantic um and what what happened with
methamphetamine was interesting years
ago the mexican trafficking world um uh
industrialized the production of meth
using a chemical known as ephedrine
ephedrine is a decongestant you find it
in sudafed pills it's chemically very
similar to meth so you a couple of
tweaks and it turns into meth it's a
it's a kind of a euphoric high very
sociable you want to be around people
you're jabbering away and they made huge
amounts of it but they were always
limited by the amount of of ephedrine
they could get and they could really get
they could get tons of it but it was
really only enough to cover parts of the
western united states never went east
the mississippi river
um eventually though the mexican
government
got got figured this out and
and
their response was to make ephedrine
essentially illegal except for certain
pharmaceutical companies to produce that
meant that the trafficking world now had
a whole body of knowledge about
methamphetamine and no way to really
make it but there is another way
of making methamphetamine and then they
began to
um
figure that out it uses a precursor
known as as you said p2p phenyl2
propanone
and p2p is actually very messy it stinks
and all that when you turn it into
methamphetamine it does have one benefit
though to the tracking in the world and
that is that you can make it many many
different ways with the lots of of
different
industrial widely available industrial
chemicals all these chemicals are legal
they're very toxic but you can if the
government cracks down on this
combination of chemicals you can use
this other one and there are many of
these combinations so it allows the
trafficking world
if they can get the chemicals
to produce this stuff in staggering
quantities and essentially that's what's
happening because they have access to
two very large ports and several smaller
ones on the pacific coast of mexico
through which they get access to the
world chemical markets and they can
bring in all the chemicals that they
like some of these chemicals actually
made in mexico of course and so what you
begin to see it beginning in about
2012-13
as the production of it is just
staggering just unbelievable quantities
of the stuff so much so that it crosses
the mississippi river goes across and
now is up into new england effectively
covering the country and it's a it's a
remarkable i guess dubious uh
achievement but there's one other thing
that that's very much a part of that
story and that is this
that as this methamphetamine begins to
really march across the country first on
the western united states in the midwest
in 2017 or so then up into new england
2019 it's also accompanied
by
very severe rapid onset symptoms
of paranoia
uh uh and and and hallucinations
symptoms of schizophrenia essentially
very intense paranoia very vivid uh
hallucinations delusions people uh so
it's accompanied by mental illness and
very quickly that mental illness leads
lots of people to be homeless so you see
as this meth marches across the country
you also find big big escalations in the
amount of mental illness and
homelessness and eventually also
uh tent encampments because at 10 these
folks under in this situation in this
condition are not going to be living in
homeless shelters right i want to talk
about that next because there's been a
big this these encampments are a big
topic of political controversy and i as
someone who is you know unabashedly on
the left i consider myself a progressive
the the research i've done makes me
question the wisdom of the kind of like
let's just leave the encampments because
if we don't have a great place to send
people who are we to take away the one
place that they found and the peace for
me in all of this that makes me hesitate
about taking that approach is
it's not when when you consider the drug
addiction component
there seems to be zero possibility that
folks get out of that cycle if they
remain in the encampment now breaking up
the encampment raises all sorts of other
questions where do people go is it safe
it's i'm not denying that but it seems
that you have no possibility of drilling
dealing with the drug component if the
encampments stay what's your experience
with that no i would say that
talking with people who work with these
folks and recovering addicts uh as well
i would say that's absolutely true and
it's really actually a little bit more
even serious than that because
talking with folks uh about this um
you very clearly quickly get the the
idea that there that
the effect of this of this
methamphetamine is really almost at
least semi-permanent
brain damage
it's not like with ephedrine myth you
would stay up for several days and you
would begin to see kind of shadow people
and then you would sleep it off and you
would return to coherence not that this
was good for you it just was not the
damage now now people are saying and i
was just speaking with a homeless
shelter provider um here in nashville
where i'm now living for for a while and
she was saying that the brain
devastation makes it so that you can't
really teach these folks to function
so the longer they are exposed out on
the street particularly intent
encampments which really exist as
vectors of methamphetamine frequently
even though of course tents were meant
with good intentions
they they they're really kind of a place
now where where meth flows flows freely
that's why they exist because people
it's like the bar where everybody knows
your name in a sense well this is the
same thing and so what what really is
happening is it prolonged exposure to
this is it's very scary and and i've met
people who who've who've recovered from
it and are now sober but they still know
they tell me that several told me this
i still know i'm not the same my brain
is still not fully healed and some of
these folks have been sober a year or
two there's still that paranoia there's
still that slow the memory is really
faded and certainly it takes weeks maybe
even months for the personality of a
person to return so it's the prolonged
exposure in these temp cameras as you
say i think makes it extraordinarily
difficult for those folks to ever
recover
to something close to what they were
beforehand
so uh sometimes you know it's very
popular to talk about portugal when one
talks about drug policy and and
treatment and one of the things that
sometimes folks don't know about
portugal is it's not that in portugal
there's no consequences for drug
addiction it's that they're handled as
health issues rather than criminal
issues but there are consequences there
can be mandated treatment
there people are taken out of the
equivalent of the encampment so to speak
so
in thinking about solutions like what
what has worked what or what might work
well i i will i do believe that that
some form of mandated treatment is is
what's necessary here because what
you're looking for in all treatment you
have to come to a point
where you embrace your sobriety where
you embrace recovery the problem is that
that
is not possible on the street today
first of all you have fentanyl which
will kill you before you ever develop
any kind of readiness for treatment
right the whole idea you need to be
ready for treatment it's true but the
problem is how do you get there where
did and how long does it take and i and
i think on the street it's very
difficult and within the meth encampment
um uh in the meth world it's very hard
for people to first of all in order for
recovery to take place you actually have
to have be able to talk
rationally with other people that it's a
human connection that is essential for
that process to move to move forward and
if you are speaking in what they call in
psychology word salad so the jumbles of
words and
tumbling out of your mouth you know no
idea what people have no idea what
you're saying there's no ability to
develop that deep connection so um first
and foremost detox and prolonged detox
not a few days but weeks and then an
idea that forced treatment because the
drugs
um control is so
um oh profound and that's what a a a
homeless outreach guy told me um
he'd been doing this five years and he
says you know everybody i've offered
treatment to and housing to when i get
them into housing very quickly they just
bolt and they leave and they run back to
the encampment
so you need to get people away from that
someplace secure
some place where they are mandated
treatment some place where they begin
the process the careful nudging gradual
process of coming to embrace their own
sobriety which will happen but it does
need that separation
from yeah that's an important point
which is when when addiction is a factor
just giving homeless folks homes alone
does not actually
solve the problem are there communities
in the u.s that are doing this correctly
i mean i think with methamphetamine it's
so new
um the story really i was i broke this
story in the book and in this in this
thing in the atlantic you know about
methamphetamine and i think many
communities kind of almost didn't know
what they had first of all covid has
kind of overshadowed everything last
year too and then before that the opioid
epidemic overshadowed the meth thing so
people have really not
come to understand the the the deep
issues involved with methamphetamine
some places
uh oh sam we just lost you we first lost
your video and then we lost your audio
now you're back sorry yeah you just
glitched for for a moment there
really yeah but now you're back you're
smooth now
uh okay well um
i would say that that a lot of places
have are still trying to figure this
thing out because first of all i think
the opioid epidemic overshadowed the
meth problem and then also then kovid
did the same yeah so what we're seeing
now is people are just kind of now
coming to understand this i would say
that in clarksburg west virginia i write
about in the book several chapters in
the book they tried the housing first
idea
and the folks that they put into housing
destroy there was some refurbished
apartments that they were able to put
them in and and they destroyed the
apartments they would you know like a
hundred thousand dollars worth of damage
to these apartments there was no way
they could do it so i think people are
just now
i mean really because the story just are
just breaking with this book you know
people are just now become coming to the
point where they're saying let's see if
what we can try i spoke with some with a
with some of a
politician in in northern california who
was thinking um we were talking about
the possibility of using uh empty big
box stores to put a kind of controlled
encampment like put tents but within a
secure big box store controlled entry
and exit and so on and have that be a
place where maybe people detox for the
first but i haven't found anybody who's
been able to deal
um
significantly with this issue that this
new meth coming out of mexico has
presented over the last several years um
sometimes people will call in and
they'll say hey are you for
legalization of all drugs just like
we're starting to see with cannabis in
some states and you know i i feel very
strongly that decriminalization is
really important and it's
there's a number of reasons why that
seems like an easier thing to think
about and there are good examples from
around the world
when i think about like recreational
meth or recreational heroin these drugs
seem
so
destructive to just one's basic ability
to exist in the world that i i have not
been convinced that recreational
legalization of these makes any sense
how do you conceive of this issue i
i i think not i guess you know i would
like to see here's what i would like to
see i guess first i would like to see us
legalize marijuana in a mature and adult
way
we are doing it as if you know
if it's if it's a if it's a consumable
um then we need to have those places
inspected
like
food factories are in spa if it's a
medicine we need to have them inspected
like like
factories that produce drugs are are
inspected i think it's absolutely insane
in a time of climate change that we
allow indoor-grown marijuana a
plant that grows beautifully outdoors
we should that should not be possible
and the idea too
that we are not going to after all never
going to be arresting people for selling
marijuana is is crazy too now you're
seeing dispensaries in california say we
have to compete now with illegal
vendors who don't have to pay taxes or
electricity or rent all the rest and and
so you need to lower our taxes no what
we need to do is we need a prolonged
prolonged time period probably many
years a very aggressive enforcement of
people who are selling the the drug
illegally so that there won't be that
that unfair um competition for folks who
actually have to pay rent and
electricity and taxes and all the rest
that we want for like any liquor store
or any any other place you know to me
this feels like oh and i also believe
that we need to to really question what
the potency should be that we allow for
for commercial for commercial sale it's
it's insane forty percent thc ninety
percent tc and vapes and this guy i mean
and and these little candy things i mean
you know when joe camel started
marketing cigarettes to kids the entire
country was up in arms and yet it's okay
to have these little gummy bears and all
that kind of stuff to me it feels like
and i think part of this grows from the
fact that we still don't have federal
marijuana legislation and really federal
marijuana legislation needs to put all
of this and much more uh in in into
place but a lot of this stuff seems to
me to be almost juvenile like it doesn't
really matter dude it's just pot well
it's it's not pot it's very potent stuff
and it needs to be treated that way and
we need to approach it like adults
i want to see that done
first and then we can turn our our our
attention to whether other drugs but i
don't really see it happening until we
do this right
no doubt about it the latest book is the
least of us true tales of america and
hope in the time of fentanyl and meth
we've been speaking with the book's
author sam quinones sam great having you
on today
love being with you david thanks so much